well there's been a lot of concern  lately after news that murder Hornets  were discovered in Washington State and  here in the u.s. in general there are  these giant Hornets from Asia and get  their name from killing honeybees an  infestation could be devastating for  beekeepers their venom is toxic and can  kill people but one expert in California  says we shouldn't be worried about them  right now at this point I tell people to  just take a deep breath and maybe have a  glass of wine and just relax because  it's a non-issue at this point now if we  found another nest or two then you  started doing some interventions but you  know that part of Washington it's pretty  far removed from California agricultural  regions and it would take them a while  to get down here so there's plenty of  time hmm hopefully they don't scientists  say the Hornets are the most destructive  in the late summer and early fall when  they are on the hunt